hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute einen
zwetschgen blechkuchen der unglaublich
lecker ich habe nämlich schon getestet
ich hab euch auf instagram gefragt ob
ihr die bei einem sketch und kuchen
möchte auf dem blech mit streuseln ganz
klassisch oder aber eine schöne torte
mit füllung oder einen normalen
klassischen kuchen ihr habt euch für die
blech variante entschieden einige von
euch gab es aber auch die wollten nur
was schönes cremiges und ich habe mir
gedacht ich vereine jetzt alles in einem
also haben jetzt einen weg kuchen mit
streuseln mit einer schönen quarkcreme
und richtig tollen leckeren zwetschgen
ich sage euch jetzt zuallererst die
zutaten für unseren boden
wir benötigen kalte butter die habe ich
schon in stückchen geschnitten außerdem
mehl zucker und backpulver unser boden
besteht jetzt aus einem rührteig und
dafür gebe ich jetzt einfach alle
zutaten zur butter und verrührt das
richtig gut und meinen händen zu einem
teig
[Musik]
nach zwei minuten hat sich der teig
schön miteinander verbunden und das
einzige was wir jetzt damit machen
müssen er braucht nämlich keine kühl
zeit gegeben den teig jetzt einfach auf
unser praktisch und da hab ich jetzt
noch den bug gramm drum herum gelegt
damit ich gleich auch einen schönen
abschluss habe falls in den nicht habt
geht es aber auch ganz einfach ohne
[Musik]
und wenn da ein backpapier drunter geht
dann gebt euch der tag auch später nicht
an
[Applaus]
sobald ihr den boden jetzt richtig schön
flach angedrückt habt kommt er zur seite
und ich zeige euch die leckere füllung
wir benötigen zwetschgen außerdem
schmand oder kind recht das könnt euch
aussuchen magerquark eier zucker mehl
und etwas zimt
zuallererst müssen wir die zwetschgen
behandeln und hierfür werden wir sie
einfach nur halbieren und die kerne
einmal raus nehmen
[Musik]
nachdem wir alle zwetschgen halbiert
haben geben wir die ganz kurz an die
seite hier könnt ihr natürlich auch
vierteln das ist auch vollkommen euch
überlassen und für die restliche cremen
die mich mir jetzt einfach eine große
schüssel ich verzichte lehne ich heute
komplett auf die küchenmaschine um euch
einfach zu zeigen dass sie die nicht
immer braucht und in die schüssel gebe
ich jetzt alle anderen zutaten verrühren
das kurz und dann kommen die zwetschge
mit dazu
[Musik]
falls ihr kein sind mit könnte den
übrigens ersetzen entweder durch vanille
das passte mal ganz gut vanillezucker
oder extrakt oder was auch ganz gut ist
vielleicht ein spritzer zitronensaft das
passt dann auch sehr gut so die
angebliche zum nach und nach unter und
die lassen sich besser verrühren wenn
sie zimmertemperatur haben
[Musik]
unsere leckere füllung ist jetzt fertig
die gebe ich jetzt noch nicht sofort
drauf sondern ich bereite jetzt erst die
streusel vor damit ich das gleich alles
ratzfatz machen kann und mir der boden
nicht durchweicht und dafür zeige ich
euch jetzt die zutaten das sind auch nur
vier wir benötigen ein mal mutter die
habe ich hier in stücke geschnitten und
die ist der weiß außerdem nötigen der
zucker hier habe ich zur hälfte weißen
und zur hälfte braunen zucker genommen
und noch etwas mehl für diesen letzten
schritt werden jetzt ganz einfach zucker
sorten und mehl butter gegeben das ganze
einmal richtig schön durchkneten und
dann sind schon unsere streusel fertig
und dann können wir das alles aus was
füllen
[Musik]
so sieht unser streusel teig dann aus
also der bleibt durchaus zusammen wenn
man ihn so festhält und festgekettet
aber wir zerbröselnden gleich und jetzt
nehme ich mir den weg gibt da die
füllung drauf und dann die sträuße warum
bist du so eine flamme sagt nur witze
dann habe ich mal meine frau ich
verstehe es mir eiskalt
[Musik]
die partei ist nur noch die streusel
drauf und die werden später richtig
lecker weil wir brauchen zucker drin
haben schmeckt auch richtig schön
karamell ich nachher
soini wir jetzt kommt unser blech in den
vorgeheizten backofen 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für 30 bis 35 minuten levels
merken wenn eure streusel richtig schön
gold frauen sind
[Musik]
und nach der backzeit habe ich den
kuchen vollständig auskühlen lassen je
ausgekühlte er ist desto fester wird er
also richtig schön in den kühlschrank
geben für eine stunde oder zwei gerne
könnt ihr auf eurem vortag zubereiten
und schmeckt er am besten mit frisch auf
geschlagener sahne die habe ich auch
nicht gelöst weil der kuchen ist ja auch
schon süß genug
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr das
rezept mal nach macht mir eure fotos mit
dem hashtag ligges kitchen auf instagram
zeigt und gerne auch dort abonniert hier
könnt ihr gern mal die glocke aktivieren
dann bekommt ihr immer eine
benachrichtigung auf ihr handy dann
verpasst ja auch nichts mehr
und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten mal wieder dabei sagt
josef laumer
[Musik]
[Applaus]